[Music]
thank you so much for having me although
in Singapore this is my first time in
Singapore and my first time in Southeast
Asia so I'm kind of excited you have
like so many good plants it's it's
pretty it's I love it and wildlife is
pretty good I'm like used to Cody's and
little trash pandas in my backyard but
you have like lizards which is really
cool
yeah way better alright so I'm gonna
talk about storytelling and I'm gonna
talk about using performance observers
to do that so I'm arena hello
I am a developer you can find me on
github I do
code for work and sometimes I maintain a
few projects here and there write up a
few projects here in there in my spare
time but in other parts of my time I
like to draw and so sometimes I draw
like random stuff but sometimes I draw
what I like to call computer art so it's
like little guides that I've put
together on several things that are
interesting in the computer world like
things on streams or working with async
hooks or how v8 works and so today's
talk is gonna be a little bit like that
but in a talk format so I've tried to
like kind of build a narrative around
using performance observers and how we
can use those as narrative in our own
applications I also like ramen so
there's a few pictures of ramen I hope
you like ramen too ate a lot of ramen
I had like 11 bowls of ramen for the 13
days I was in Japan and December it was
pretty great
so hello storytelling performance
observers like I said we're gonna try to
build it a little bit of a narrative as
to how we can build out applications
know a little bit more about them as we
work in our enid process
so mostly I'll be talking about node but
there might be some kind of browser
references to that as well so why are we
even here like why why do we want to
kind of find out more about our
applications I think that comes down to
the fact that we like we need to have
more knowledge as to what's going on we
want to know or when a request comes in
and what happens after that and how long
does it take for us to look up a thing
in the database how long does it take us
to do I put in the database what's the
difference between writing to the
database versus writing to Redis and
these kinds of metrics we kind of we
kind of want to know it all and
sometimes it's hard in your processes
but we want to know the numbers anyway
and numbers are pretty important so
that's kind of the thing like we want to
know the numbers because numbers gets us
places and then we can either improve or
I don't know I don't know if we want to
not improve but or stay the same in
terms of how we build stuff out it's
numbers numbers are pretty important but
where numbers takes us is you know to
kind of keep on with us with a theme of
storytelling and having a narrative a
lot of the times what we'll do to get
some sort of story or some sort of
tracking in our applications as having
loggers so there's one like you know
there is a pinot logger that gets just a
little bit of information about what
happens in our application we put that
together with our server and we get some
data out so we can see how long like how
long something takes can probably get a
little bit more from the process ID and
we kind of can use that information to
our advantage and kind of build out that
narrative so loggers loggers are great
but we wanted to kind of go from numbers
and we want to be able to track some
sort of information from there right we
don't want to just have numbers that are
unrelated to each other so we want to go
from numbers to tracking and eventually
maybe go to something like tracing to be
able to actually build a proper
narrative about our
so tracing wood is tracing strange I
wasn't listening to Bobby when I was
putting this together but I don't know
just kinda came to mind so open tracing
IO is a pretty good source or pretty
good kind of metric or sorry not we're
talking the word I'm looking for a
standard so they've put together kind of
a thing about what tracing does so
tracing tells you a story of a
transaction so tracing is a lot about
what a workflow does and what a
transaction does in your system and you
want to be able to kind of propagate it
through a system and see what it is that
you come up with so eventually you
basically have like a single parent and
a single parent has a bunch of children
that it spins up like different
processes that start off with a single
parent those children can have other
children and so eventually you kind of
build out this tree so the way to think
about it is that for example you have a
play in four parts the play itself is a
trace or parent and then the four parts
are like the spans and like the acts in
the four parts or the spans spans and
things like that so it's kind of like
your story but in a more technical point
of view and so like I said before a
trace is a trace is useful to put
together transaction right so a
transaction is something like a request
so putting together a history of a
request will build a trace of the said
request so if we were to look at
something like this we are then able to
say that okay our entire trace is this
and then it soul spans is an actual post
request and then from that post request
we went to authenticate the user we went
to from that post request get the data
save it to Redis but we also wanted to
save it to the database so these are the
two spans that can work at the same time
and then part of that is we want to send
back some sort of message to the user
and so that entire thing makes up the
trace and these different transactions
kind of put together in there
and so that I talked about tracing but
then I want to like go back to the
performance timeline and the performance
API so it's interesting to know the
narrative and tracing kind of helps us
build that narrative about what it is
that's going on but I wanted to look
into the performance timeline and the
performance API and see what kind of
information I can get from using that
kind of thing so what happened is that
performance timeline kind of got put
together by the w3c and that's what got
implemented in both the browser and node
so window dot performance if most
browsers now support this you're able to
kind of get whatever the information you
need on timing and navigation in window
performance the equivalent to that is
require perfect and note in node greater
than 8.5 so then you're kind of getting
the same thing by requiring per folks
and having the performance object there
are so also timings and node origin and
that's kind of thing so per folks or is
is the establishment of what an
application timeline is so what is an
application timeline so essentially it
is a timeline so a request or a trace of
their quests like we talked to you we're
talking about the trace so kind of the
same thing request you start off with
that and the things that happened
throughout that and the things you can
measure go together in an application
timeline so in a case of browser you're
kind of looking at a few different
things you're looking at when they're
reserved loads you're looking at a pain
time you might be looking at the
navigation so these are the kinds of
things that go inside the performance
timeline
so let's actually dig a little bit
deeper so require perfect let's look
into it so we're able to get a few
things from performed dot performance
per folks and
the access to mark and measure so what
are these mark and measure things well
the easiest way to go about it was
actually like digging through the API
so when you want to get something to be
marked or measured within your
performance timeline you basically want
to find out how long something takes to
load or how long's a process takes to
run or like if you're running a loop
like how long does it take you to get
through the entire look kind of thing so
what you'll start off with is you mark a
start point in your timeline or and in
your application you mark an end point
in your application and then you are
able to run a doc measure on it and see
how long that piece of code takes to run
you're then able to get entries from it
and seeing what exactly that particular
entry looks like it's start time its
duration what type it is is it and then
afterwards you've got to clear it like
erase it all together so it's not part
of your timeline anymore so what it
looks like code wise is like this so for
example we have a simple post request
that we're trying to make we're pressing
the data or we're writing into the
database and then what we want to do is
we want to set a mark in the beginning
of that pork's request just to see how
long the the put actually takes how long
does it take us to spit the data back up
to your client what you're then able to
do is mark an end within that put and
you are then able to measure it out from
start to end
so something like this and then once
you're able to get the entries of that
particular start to end measurement out
you're able to print it off and see how
long something like that take so this is
an example that I wrote making a raman
database for myself so I can know all
the good ramen shops and remember them
because at this point I went to too many
and I don't remember so I heard Keisuke
is good in Singapore somebody tell me
otherwise or like tell me a different
one so you get the performance entry out
and it's got the
the entry type start time and the
duration so able to work with that and
see how long something like that takes
cool and this is again like to zoom in
this is what the entry object looks like
name entry type start time and how long
it actually takes really useful for
debugging
so let's actually zoom in into that
performance entry so we started off by
saying we have a time line we have
certain entries inside that time line
certain things that need to load but
let's look at the performance buffer so
performance buffer is where we put all
of the entries in so every time we do a
mark like we did an example and know
what every time there's a garbage
collection entry or a function entry or
a note entry these kinds of things they
all go into the performance buffer so
there is like a used up space and unused
up space which means there and the thing
about the the buffer itself is that
there's only 150 entries you can have in
there which means you've got to clear
them so when I was mentioning previously
like we've got a clear at the end of the
the mark and the measure it's because
the buffer fills up and then we get
memory leaks so you kind of want to make
sure the buffer is consistently cleared
and so there's a few different types of
them note has different ones in the
browser so I'm gonna do the comparison
here so node has mark and measure node
garbage collection function 8 and http2
for now maybe there will be more once a
few more pull requests come in kind of
thing and the browser also does the
paint events and the frames and
navigation and resources cool but like I
said previously we this buffer only has
150 entries so we've got to be able to
clear it as we go
so you clear that by just calling duck
clear and to like give you an example of
what it looks like it's just clear marks
and clear measures and clear functions
are the ones that are present in node so
if we were to clear it and then call
measure again
we'll get will basically throw cool so
you clear it clearly buffer there but
the thing about this is like okay we're
kind of marking these as we go along as
we're debugging the application or we're
trying to establish like some
differences between writing toyotas and
writing to the database for example but
we need to be able to keep track of
these so a good way to look at this is
using the performance observers so what
our performance observers what are we
observing really so a performance
observer is just an instance that takes
a callback that works with the list of
the performance entries so the ones we
talked about previously and the observer
object so essentially in your
application you go through certain
entries so like the marks and the
measures that we were doing in the above
example and some stuff that note gives
you as is like garbage collection events
obviously you don't specifically mark
them and all those entries go into the
their observers list so all of them just
kind of keep on piling up in there and
then what you're able to do with that
list is actually get some information
out of there so a good example of that
is so this is how you would set it up
right like have a few entry types you
want to monitor and you want to your
observe it to work with function measure
I kind of just put them all together and
then what you do is say okay I'm gonna
buffer them as well so that they all
come in like a sync and then once I
launch my application I get the garbage
collection events and then the ones that
I've marked previously to kind of get
there and I'm actually probably just
going to show you what I did because
that code sample was kind of small
all right how's the font size on that
okay all right so I worked with the
entry types and then what my what my
server did so I just set up like a basic
server what I set up in my server is I
marked a few events so one here and then
I just put one in a loop so it like runs
through and afterwards are clear the
marks and what my handler dars is just
it looks at the entries that come back
so then if we were to launch the server
we'll get the to garbage collection
events and then we'll get the actual
marks that we are watching for they'll
come back and is like nice list that you
can then work with and log out and maybe
do some more information with it now I
wanted to I just switched to team acts
so I'm like my fingers are used to my
previous bindings and I keep pressing
the previous bindings and they don't
work muscle-memory am i right so I'm
gonna run start and then I'm just gonna
curl because oh no this wasn't even like
a demo demo I'm already sucking at this
so I'm gonna actually run a node example
yes cuz that was a different thing so I
get the two performance entries for the
garbage collection to do two and then
I'm gonna run the nice little soft serve
on a tea and then I get all the other
marks that I've put in there cool so we
get these like objects all in one
convenient spot and we can monitor them
through the performance observer in our
applications which is great
so there's I just like these two modules
I wanted to introduce you to so they
used to only have because the
performance API is available in both the
browser and the server these two worked
with just the browser's api's and I just
patched them so they both no work would
note and make it a little bit easier so
instead of you having to set up the
entire observer kind of just on
performance just observing for you and I
know timing handles the timing entries
which were the first things we talked
about so it's kind of easy to get to
work with that and then once you're able
to use those or just observers
performance observer API or at the mark
and measure it kind of can just put them
into like any application node
application you want like you can work
make it work with FASTA Phi or like the
one I work on is Mary but either/or like
you can just put that in your
application and kind of start seeing how
you can work with those but kind of the
things I wanted to talk about is that
okay so I was playing around with these
and I wanted to do quite a bit of like
storytelling with performance observers
but what I ended up finding out is that
it's mark and measure super useful to be
able to figure out like how long
something takes in your application and
it's useful for debugging like
development purposes but it doesn't
actually build like a narrative property
properly because you're not able to kind
of put anything together and you want to
be able to have a story and you want to
be able to put a trace together and you
want to be able to kind of chain things
and that's a little bit harder with
observables so I found that it's like
it's definitely a development thing and
development environment thing to be able
to kind of predict that before you
deploy to production kind of thing so
building narrative is hard but the thing
that I found is that okay so I want to
be able to build narrative and the API
that I like for that is actually async
hooks and this talk was not meant to be
about acing hoops but I wanted to
briefly mention them as well so with
that with async Oh
so I think I'm able to build an actual
proper kind of trackable narrative that
I want to be able to see in my
application code and because performance
observers kind of add and performance
api adds a bit of an overhead in your
application async Oaks are much less so
and plus they add a little bit of a
narrative to it so you gotta kind of
balance those out as to what what is you
gotta cost it out like as to what you
want but like I said I didn't want this
talk to be on ASA cook so I just briefly
mentioning them and there's like a talk
that Thurston Lawrence did add note
convey about them he's done a bunch of
work with them and it's like really good
and I also wrote a little guide for them
as well if you want to look into that
and there's like a module that actually
helps you create traceable events that
you can specifically Rison to and build
a better narrative so kind of wrapping
up as to what we talked about so we
talked about the performance timeline we
talked about being able to look at the
timeline and see kind of what
performance entries we can look at and
what kind of useful information we can
derive from them so that we also talked
about the specific mark and measure and
using those to be able to debug certain
parts of our application and work with
those parts of our applications and we
also talked about the fact that once we
were able to get all of our entries in
one place we're able to see and compare
what exactly that they do in our
application using the performance
observer portion of the API yeah so that
was the talk I wanted to give I am
really happy that you're able to have me
I hope you enjoyed it and if you have
any more questions come say hi on
Twitter or just come say hi
you